ninety percent of all land plants need
to have a plant fungus root Association
you can see the fungus which exists in
most of its life as thin filaments and
the network of thin filaments we call it
mycelium and the mycelium of the fungus
can tap into the root of plants and make
a symbiosis and by there they exchange
nutrients that the other one isn't so
good at at making or capturing but it
doesn't stop there because the fungi can
tap into other plants at the same time
so what you end up is this massive
underground Network mediated by fungi
now it's not just nutrients that are
flowing also communication because
plants can talk to each other through
the fungal Network to create chemical
signals to be able to warn a pest attack
for example